Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Prittlav und das hier ist Ausgabe einundvierzig und äh,
Heute gibt's mal wieder Corona Weekly, diesmal wirklich Weekly, denn ja in schnellerer Folge als jetzt zuletzt finden wir uns wieder zusammen, nämlich ich und natürlich Pabel, hallo Pabel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau, denn äh es ist es ist ja, es ist ja mal wieder viel Musik in äh in den in den ersten Zahlenwerk, was wir hier betrachten. Das dürfte ja jedem schon aufgefallen sein. Ich merk's auch gerade wieder äh am,
Laten zusammenbrechen bei einer Reiseplanung. Habe ich auch so geil getan. Ich hatte das letzte Mal, als ich so so eine Reise äh ausführlich geplant habe, war das genau im März und dann bin ich so richtig in den Lokdown reingerasselt und jetzt hatte ich wieder so ein Ding. Alles stand,
minutiös geplant und ich habe wieder genau,
die Woche getroffen und jetzt kriege ich nur so Mails mit, ja schwierig, neue Verordnungen, bei uns darf keiner mehr rein.
Und ein Termin hätte ich in der Schweiz gehabt, ich glaub den werde ich einfach,
kätzelt, weil da habe ich irgendwie schon äh viel zu viel gehört über Komplikationen an der Grenze und Quarantäne und haste nicht gesehen und ich glaube, das werde ich mir dann auch äh schenken können. Jetzt versuche ich grad noch das Beste rauszuholen, was irgendwie geht.
Ja und natürlich auch als Berliner äh so ähm.
Ursünde der des deutschen Zahlenwerks.
Ja, es war wahrscheinlich auch nirgendwo äh so richtig gerne gesehen äh im Moment ähm aber na ja.
Die Unterschiede sind ja jetzt auch nicht mehr so signifikant, also diese dieses Blam Game, was da gespielt wird, das ist auch ein bisschen albern, ne? Weil alle, die sich heute aufregen, haben da eine Woche später die selben Zahlen.
Neukölln ist auch nur noch auf Platz drei, aber da kommen dann später zu.
Genau, fangen wir mal äh mit Feedb,
äh an. Wir haben ja ähm wieder einige Kommentare bekommen, die können wir jetzt hier in der Gänze natürlich nicht wiedergeben, relativ viel auch zu der Diskussion, um Crowd Not die Feier, viel Kryptographie, Details, etcetera, PP. Hier machen wir mal so zwei, drei Sachen rausgepickt
Erstmal kam hier der Hinweis äh auf ähm,
unseren Sprach äh Gebrauch. Ihr redet von der Falsch-Positivrate, diese ist definiert als der Anteil fälschlicherweise positiver Test.
An der Summe aller positiven Tests,
heißt bei einer Rate von ein Prozent falsch positiver Test sind bei hundert positiven Test. Neunundneunzig Personen wirklich krank und nur eine Person fälschlich als krank eingestuft worden. Das ist also echt zu vernachlässigen,
Ja, ich bin mir gar nicht so ganz so sicher, was wir da jetzt richtig oder falsch gesagt haben, aber.
Es äh widerspricht jedenfalls nicht unsere Haltung des äh oder Überzeugung, äh dass es äh tatsächlich einfach zu vernachlässigen äh ist, dass die Tests
genau genug sind und das ist nicht allzu viele Leute
gibt die als äh falsch positiv äh eingestuft werden. So,
äh also unabhängig davon, wie man jetzt rechnet und äh ja.
Zweiter Hinweis, Pavel meinte sinngemäß in Norwegen und Griechenland sei es noch nicht so schlimm, ich stimme zu, ich wüsste aber gerne, was an den griechischen Zahlen anzweifelt, denn basierend auf dem allgemein zugänglichen Zahlenmaterial ist in beiden Ländern das Verhältnis der Anzahl der Todesfälle zur Anzahl der Infektionen,
sowie die Anzahl Todesfälle pro Million doch recht ähnlich, warum zweifelt er die Zahlen aus Norwegen nicht ebenfalls an,
Wäre wünschenswert solche Aussagen wieder, stimmt was, nicht auch zu begründen.
OK.
Herr Meier, erklären sie sich.
Ja das war, ich bin da jetzt auch nicht in die Tiefe gegangen, aber wenn man sich einfach den Ländervergleich äh anguckt
Data kann man sich die ja schön nebeneinander klicken auch. Dann sieht man, dass,
in Griechenland, zum einen in den letzten Wochen deutlich viele Leute gestorben sind
So, also während in Norwegen nicht so das war, das war eigentlich der Punkt für mich, dass ich gesagt habe, Moment mal, äh wie kann das sein, dass
ja die Zahl der Toten so stark gestiegen ist. Ähm.
Und die Zahl der Infektionen aber nicht. Das hat mich halt ein bisschen
stützig gemacht. So und jetzt ist es auch noch so, dass gut, dass wir zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht ganz so klar, aber in Griechenland zieht jetzt auch die Zahl der Infektionen,
an. Also meine Vermutung war einfach, dass irgendwie nicht allzu viel getestet wird. So, das war ähm,
mein Punkt, aber äh auf jeden Fall wenn man jetzt die Zahlen nebeneinander hält, sieht man Norwegen.
Sind die Zahlen konstant und sowohl also es sterben kaum Leute und es gibt auch keine kein Anstieg bei den Neuinfektionen.
In Griechenland äh gibt es den Anstieg bei beiden. Also ja.
Schon bestätigt sozusagen. Gut, dann kommen wir ja mal zu dem, was uns alle natürlich am meisten interessiert.
Die Zahlen in Deutschland. Spoiler, sieht nicht so gut aus.
Sieht genauso nicht so gut aus, wie es vor einer Woche nicht so gut ausgesehen hat. Also da hat sich jetzt nichts dran geändert, eigentlich seit zwei Wochen
schießen die Zahlen in die Höhe ohne ja
ohne dass es irgendwie so aussieht als wenn da irgendwas zum Stillstand kommen würde oder sich verlangsamen würde obwohl ich eigentlich damit rechne, dass ich das irgendwie mal ein bisschen verlangsamt allein aufgrund der Tatsache dass,
viele Leute, wie ich hoffe
Zahlen zur Kenntnis nehmen und sich vorsichtig vorsichtiger verhalten und ja und es wurden auch bestimmte Maßnahmen verschärft, ob die Maßnahmen jetzt bringen oder die Tatsache, dass
die Leute jetzt aufgrund der Maßnahmen,
ihr Verhalten ändern oder sich das Bewusstsein generell auf jeden Fall müsste eigentlich bald was passieren, wenn da gar nichts passiert,
in der nächsten Woche, also wenn wir nicht wenigstens eine leichte Verlangsamung sehen und,
Sie sehen wir seit zwei Wochen nicht. Seit zwei Wochen haben wir da einen relativ konstantes äh R und ähm.
Ja bei ja über eins Komma drei seit einer Woche.
Seit zwei Wochen fast fast seit zwei Wochen ja.
Geht es hier richtig zur Sache davor waren wir zwar auch meistens über eins, aber immer nur so leicht so eins Komma eins, eins Komma zwei so eins Komma zwei fünf,
Aber jetzt haben wir eher so eins Komma drei fünf
in der Gegend, also zwischen eins Komma drei und eins Komma vier und das seit zwei Wochen und das sieht man der Kurve der Neuinfektion einfach an, die.
Die hoppst ordentlich nach oben.
Richtig, richtig steil nach oben.
Und wir haben auch neue Rekordtageswerte. Gut, was man auch immer dazu sagen muss, die Dunkelziffer ist deutlich niedriger als jetzt im März und April, sodass man,
jetzt nicht direkt vielleicht eins zu eins vergleichen kann, sondern eigentlich müsste man die Zahlen halbieren bis vierteln ungefähr, um sie mit den März und Aprilzahlen vergleichen,
zu können aber ja nichtsdestotrotz sind das die Zahlen die wir gerade haben.
Auf welcher Basis würdest du denn jetzt die Dunkelziffer bestimmen? Ich meine du bist ja in deiner Tabelle,
glaube ich, hast du jetzt noch keine Änderung gemacht, da gehst du ja im Prinzip noch mit dieser alten Annahme aus, dass wir quasi nur ein Sechsel der Infektionen sehen,
dann sind ja die Tests doch deutlich ausgeweitet worden. Die äh Infektion insgesamt auch weiter zurückgegangen. Das heißt, diese äh positive äh wie heißt die Rate noch gleich? Die Testpositivrate, die.
Viel halt dann doch deutlich ab, sodass man eben sagen kann, na ja es wird viel getestet. Man findet wenig.
Da kann jetzt die Dunkelziffer nicht mehr so hoch sein.
Gibt's denn irgendein Gradmesser, irgendeiner eine Annäherung oder zumindest unsere Pi mal Daumenregel, wie du jetzt diese Dunkelziffer sehen würdest und warum sagst du, ist sie jetzt sozusagen.
Immer noch gering und wo ist sie überhaupt? Also was erlaube Dunkelziffer.
Letztlich was die meisten Leute auch machen, die versuchen irgendwie hinter die Dunkelziffer zu kommen,
bis dann die Zahl der Hospitalisierten, also die schweren Fälle und insbesondere weil die Zahl der schweren Fälle nicht so leicht abrufbar ist oder abfragbar ist.
Ähm die Zahl der Todesfälle, dass man die halt in Relation setzt zu den Zahl der Positivtests und.
Da kann man sehen, äh hatten wir ja im,
April Ende März, Anfang April zwischen zwei und vier Mal so viel.
Tote zu dem Zeitpunkt, als wir dieselben Zahlen an Neuinfizierten hatten, alles jetzt im sieben Tage Schnitt.
Ja sah das mit den Toten.
Eher schlimmer aus, was jetzt nicht heißt, dass es jetzt nicht noch schlimmer kommen wird, das aber ich erwarte jetzt erstmal nicht so den ganz, ganz großen Berg, aber auf jeden Fall das Verhältnis, einfach zu neu von neu infizierten,
zu toten, wobei man dann gewissen zeitlichen Abstand äh auch noch äh sehen muss, weil natürlich die Leute deutlich später äh versterben als dass äh sie Symptome zeigen und,
im positiven Test kriegen.
Hey meine wir haben das ja schon mehrfach besprochen, dass dass diese erste Welle, also die das Zahlenmaterial, was wir von dieser ersten Welle hatten.
Ich will nicht sagen, unbrauchbar ist, aber zumindest schwer zum Vergleich herangezogen werden kann. Also äh allein schon die Betrachtung der der Toten, die wir zu diesem Zeitpunkt haben, wenn ich jetzt mal hier auf äh Anfang April blicke,
Anfang Mitte April, das war so der Peak, der der Sterberate. Sprich, wenn ich da zurückgehe, drei Wochen oder auch äh vier Wochen zurückgehe.
Äh und dann
quasi die Zahl der gezählten Infektionen, also die die wir durch Tests haben, messen können äh mit dieser Todesrate in Verhältnisse und das Gleiche mal jetzt in die aktuelle Situation übertrage, dann dann steht
irgendwie in keinem Verhältnis zueinander. So, also müssen eigentlich die Infektionszahlen damals eben sehr viel größer gewesen sein und sagen wir mal, du lagst mit deiner Dunkelziffer da irgendwie richtig, ja?
Dann ist halt die Frage, okay von welcher Dunkelziffer können wir jetzt ausgehen und wann passt du deine Tabelle an?
Ja gut, mit der Tabelle habe ich schon gesagt, da konnte ich mich mit mir selbst äh noch nicht
einigen, welchen neuen Wert ich denn äh jetzt nehmen soll, weil sich der Wert natürlich auch ständig ändert. Äh zum einen mit der positiven Rate
und zum anderen gehe ich auch nochmal davon aus, dass die Dunkelziffer,
lokal auch noch äh sehr verschieden ist und auch noch in den Altersgruppen verschieden ist. So. Insofern ja,
Schwierig, ich könnte sie jetzt halbieren, aber ja, wie gesagt,
Ich konnte mich noch nicht dazu durchregen und an der Platzierung ändert das jetzt auch wirklich nichts. Sondern die Reihe Rangfolge wäre immer noch dieselbe und
ja gut es würde vielleicht an den,
Farben etwas ändern an bei den sozusagen Farben für die Risikoeinstufung so, aber man kann's im Moment auch einfach gedanklich halbieren ähm.
Oder vierteln den Risikowert beziehungsweise mal zwei oder vier multiplizieren. Das heißt, wenn da jetzt,
eins zu hundert steht, dann werden's vielleicht irgendwas eins zu zweihundert bis eins zu vierhundert ungefähr als.
Größenordnung bis man äh äh sagen wie jeder wie vielte äh ansteckend ist.
Will ja eigentlich nur wissen, wie viele Zombies mir derzeit in Berlin so begegnen.
Ja, also.
Ich meine wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie äh beide im Stadtteil, also Bezirk Pankow,
so der immerhin auf Platz zweihundertsechsundzwanzig gefallen ist, das ist schon mal ganz gut und dein aktuelles Risiko so ausrechnet, dass es eins zu hundertvierzehn.
Dann,
ist es wahrscheinlich dann irgendwie ein eher jeder zweihundertste bis vierhundertste, äh den der dir über den Weg läuft,
Aber ähm.
Sagt, das hängt dann so ein bisschen noch auch, wenn natürlich stark von äh ja vom Alter ab, von der Altersgruppe. Ich habe mich sogar tatsächlich ähm ja nachdem ich,
die Institzen äh gesehen hatte in den verschiedenen Altersgruppen, zu denen wir auch noch kommen wollten, habe ich mir dann schon immer, wenn ich mit jemandem
aus dieser Altersgruppe der zwanzig bis Dreißigjährigen zusammen war, habe ich mich dann schon gefragt, hm, setze ich mich jetzt gerade einem deutlich erhöhten Risiko äh äh aus, äh weil ich jetzt genau diese junge Person
treffe.
Da was triffst du auch junge Personen? Also ich gehe denen aus dem Weg.
Ja.
Soweit ich kann, ne? Ich meine gestern nochmal Reality-Check gemacht so und äh in die Bars geguckt und na ja, also ähm.
Ja, so richtig leer sind die Bars nicht, hä?
Nee, nein, sind sie nicht und die sitzen da alle rum und ohne Masken und es wird gequatscht und ist alles wie früher. Ähm.
Nur nur drinnen statt draußen. Mhm.
Genau. Drinnen äh statt draußen, draußen sitzen dann so die Älteren,
Die dürfen frieren, aber äh können sich halt sozusagen noch so ein bisschen äh isolieren, aber drinnen habe ich's, also was ist so eine Mischung aus jungen, unbedarften
Älteren, wo ich mich frage, ob die sich gerade versuchen, irgendwie eine Entscheidung abzunehmen oder was, also es linkt mir da eine Logik drin zu sehen im Verhalten.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, also wenn man dann unter eine Kneipe geht, sollte man wahrscheinlich am ehesten in eine Raucherkneipe gehen, weil die die besten Lüftungsanlagen,
äh haben, die sind halt auf dem höchsten Luftaustausch äh ausgerichtet, sodass man da wenigstens irosoltechnisch wahrscheinlich am besten bedient ist.
Horrorkneipen sind insofern vielleicht ganz hilfreich als dass man an der Bewegung des Rauchs auch ganz gut sehen kann wie die anderen Viren sich auch alle so bewegen. Nur mal so als Tipp.
Genau, das ist die die andere Sache, genau und ähm.
Falls ihr Zigaretten riecht, dann dann könntet ihr theoretisch auch Viren riechen. Falls wir ihn riechen würden.
Mhm. Genau, es ist äh nämlich auch ja also zumindest wenn es sich äh Arosol mäßig verbreitet, weil Zigaretten, Rauch, oh Wunder ist auch ein Eirosol, also ein ja.
Etwas, was in Luft gelöst ist als feine Teilchen. Genau. Wenn man,
den Rauch von jemandem riechen kann, dann kann man auch äh ja korona Vieren äh potenziell inhalieren. Zwar nicht so wahrscheinlich, aber nicht unmöglich.
So kann man sich's auf jeden Fall gut vorstellen.
Mhm.
Wenn man sich die Zahl der Toten jetzt in Deutschland mal anguckt und dann mal zurückgeht in den April auf dieselbe Größenordnung und dann.
Oben geht zu der blauen Kurve, ja ist ungefähr dann die Hälfte, also.
Das war jetzt dann auch so ein bisschen meine These, dass ich, wie gesagt, die wahrscheinlich die dunkelziffer ungefähr halbiert hat. Was bedeuten würde, dass wir immer noch ungefähr dreimal so viel infizierte äh oder ansteckende hätten,
wie die offiziellen Zahlen ausweisen.
Ja. Aber vielleicht auch weniger, als wir eben in dieser ersten Welle hatten, weil sie's einfach schon.
Ja, definitiv.
Ausgebrochen hat.
Also das kann man definitiv, das kann man definitiv festhalten.
Ansonsten habe ich mir auch nochmal die Mühe gemacht, diesmal äh selber mal aus dem RKI Surf Stutt.
Ähm das ist so ein Tool. Weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erwähnt hatte, mit dem kann man sich äh selber.
Daten rausziehen.
Die äh zum Beispiel eigene Altersgruppen auch machen und feinere Altersgruppen und so. Also das sind halt ein bisschen mehr Daten äh drin, aber es ist jeweils nur.
Pro Woche, also Woche ist die kleinste Auflösung, man hat da keine Tageswerte äh mit drin und.
Die aktuelle Woche bis noch nicht zu Ende. So, also da, wenn man in reinguckt,
dann ja sind die, muss man beachten, dass die Zahlen für die für die aktuelle Woche noch steigen werden. Und für alle anderen Wochen dann auch noch, weil die da wird vom Meldedatum ausgegangen und die Surfsdat ist jetzt nicht nur für
Corona, beziehungsweise Kovit, äh sondern für alle möglichen anderen Erkrankungen hoch,
Ja und da kann man sich halt ganz einfach so seine Auswertung zusammenklicken. Ich habe dann mal eine,
nach ja,
Inzidenz und Altersstufen jeweils in in fünf Jahren äh gemacht und.
Muss man ja nochmal dazu sagen, wir hatten das ja letztes Mal beklagt, dass diese Altersgruppen nicht fein genug aufgelöst sind. Hier sind sie das.
Ja, also aber was ist denn inwiefern ist denn denn das jetzt ein anderes Zahlenmaterial? Und warum hat man diese hat man diese Auflösung aus den anderen Daten äh so bisher nicht.
Ja, weil.
Bei den anderen Daten sind dafür wiederum mehr andere Informationen enthalten und tagesaktueller enthalten. Also es ist einfach eine andere Art von Auswertung
würde mich nicht fundern wenn die das irgendwie,
mit dem Surfstud oder wenn der Surfstudt da irgendwie auch mit dranhängt oder so. Ich weiß es nicht nicht genau, aber es ist definitiv ein komplett
andere Art die Daten sich zu holen. Und hier kann ich mir auch keine Rohdaten äh holen, sondern ich kann mir nur Auswertungen zusammenklicken.
Und dann wirft er mir halt eine Tabelle aus mit den entsprechenden Auswertungen, die ich da.
Dann eingestellt habe.
Der Vorteil ist, hier kriegt man natürlich jetzt die Altersgruppen sehr fein aufgelöst, ich weiß nicht, was das Maximum ist, man kann da kann im Prinzip jedes ein Jahr okay und du hast
mal hier so in fünf, fünf Jahre Schritten aufgelöst, um mal so ein bisschen so ein Bild zu bekommen, wo denn eigentlich die Aktivität ist? Und da können wir das jetzt im Prinzip nur auf Basis der KW zweiundvierzig sagen, weil die dreiundvierzig halt grad noch äh läuft.
Und ja, was was können wir dem entnehmen.
Ist immer noch die zwanzig bis vierundzwanzigjährigen die,
die höchste Insidenz haben, aber äh fünfundzwanzig bis Neunundzwanzigjährigen
liegen da dicht auf. Also ist jetzt kein großer Unterschied, das heißt es nach wie vor die zwanzig bis dreißigjährigen danach noch die Fünfunddreißigjährigen
so dann die.
Fünfzehn bis neunzehn.
Ja, stimmt. Ja, dann die fünfzehn bis Neunzehnjährigen, ja als nächstes genau. Und dann also es geht dann wächst dann so ein bisschen, rechts und links, na ja, nicht ganz,
Dann haben wir jetzt nochmal 'ne Häufung im Moment zwischen fünfzig.
Neunundfünfzig auch, also sowohl fünfzig bis vierundfünfzig als auch fünfundfünfzig bis neunundfünfzig.
Sie sind uns auf der Spurpabe. Wie kommen uns zu holen?
Na ja, das sind dann äh die äh Familienväter, die dann in die Mitlive-Crisis äh kommen und sich dann irgendwo draußen rumtreiben und mehr ausgehen und.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Na, stimmt.
Aus dem Haus sind ja und die dann bisschen mehr auf die Kacke hauen ja.
Gewagte These. Ich meine, genauso betrifft's natürlich dann eigentlich auch die Eltern zu Hause, wenn die Kinder das aus der Schule mitbringen, also ist ein bisschen schwierig. Äh äh feiern, wenn ich mir das so anschaue, das schreit mich nicht jetzt gerade mit dem Wort Schule an.
Nee, nicht so richtig, das stimmt, weil ähm ja,
Also zwischen zehn und wobei ja zwischen fünfzehn und neunzehn ist dann aber auch noch deutlich höher als zwischen zehn und vierzehn. Das
stimmt, wobei ja zehn zwischen zehn und vierzehn ist äh genauso wie sechzig bis vierundsechzig, also die gleiche Inzidenz.
Es sieht für mich nicht aus in dieser Headmap nicht nicht wie so ein so ein Treiber, sondern der der Treiber ist irgendwie ganz klar zwanzig bis vierundzwanzig.
Das ist sozusagen das da, wo es am meisten flammt und wo es dann wie du schon sagst so äh links und rechts äh ausfedert und dann äh ab und zu vielleicht auch mal eine Alterskategorie überspringt,
Und das ist ähm ja, das ist ähm.
Ich weiß nicht, was das mir sah, was mir das sagen will, weil ich auch ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten habe da mir vorzustellen, was wohl eigentlich so die Primäre,
Aktivität ist in dieser Altersgruppe.
Klar, da hast du Auszubildende drin, da hast du Studierende drin, da hast du äh auch Leute, die einfach schon im Beruf stehen,
Was Leute, die viel ausgehen vielleicht, deutlich höherer Anteil, das ist einfach so sagen wir mal,
Alter, in dem man einfach eine hohe soziale Mobilität hat, wo man neue Leute kennenlernt, äh permanent mit auch mit mehreren Gruppen zu tun hat
permanent sich umentscheidet, wie man den jetzt äh äh eigentlich gerade am interessantesten findet und das ist ja auch vollkommen normal. Und ich glaube, dass das schon ein Faktor sein kann.
Genau, das ist also das ist zumindest äh der Faktor, den ich.
Am plausibelsten finde ähm dass ja es halt einfach,
Verbindungen in ganz viele andere Gruppen gibt, dass es Kontakte gibt zu den Eltern, dass es viele Kontakte vielleicht noch gibt, zu jüngeren Geschwistern, ähm dass es Kontakte gib,
in Schule, Uni, Beruf, äh dass die Freundeskreise außerdem nicht ganz so festgelegt,
sind so oder festgefügt sind, wie in späteren Jahren, das heißt ja, wahrscheinlich einfach viele Kontakte,
und dann offensichtlich auch in Verbindung mit dann nicht allzu viel Schutz bei den Kontakten,
oder nicht allzu viel Vorsicht bei Kontak.
Genau, alles so ein bisschen immer noch dadurch gefüttert durch dieses und passiert ja eigentlich auch nichts,
äh was was kann mir schon passieren äh Corona kann kommen? Ja, ist halt nur blöd, weil man dann eben selber äh das Viro ist auf dem Silbertaumplatt durch die Gegend trägt.
Wir sehen halt jetzt gerade also in der.
In der Woche in der KW zweiundvierzig einen Sprung bei den achtzig plus bei der Insidenz, was so aber auch gleichzeitig die,
gefährdetste Kategorie ist, äh muss man sagen und.
Wir haben wahrscheinlich jetzt ja in dieser Kalenderwoche.
Ja, also da wird auf jeden Fall noch einiges dazu kommen. Ähm und wir haben bis jetzt schon auch fast die zweiundvierzig erreicht in der Altersgruppe und da kommt kommt sicher noch was.
Bestimmt noch ein Drittel dazu. Also alles nicht schön.
Vielleicht nochmal ein ein Wort zu den ähm Tests, wie sie derzeit gefahren werden und du hattest, glaube ich, auch nochmal einen Blick auf den Probenrückstau äh geworfen, ne.
Mhm. Genau, ja, also Tests sind wir jetzt bei rund eins Komma zwei Millionen. Ist ein bisschen gestiegen von, ich sage mal rund,
ja von eins Komma eins acht sechs auf eins Komma eins neun fünf so. Also die Zahl der Tests,
ist fast konstant während aber die positiven Quote von zweieinhalb auf drei Komma sechs Prozent gestiegen ist. Also da hat sich richtig was getan und,
Also es bedeutet halt nur, dass äh im Gegensatz zur ersten Welle, wo zeitgleich die Tests massiv hochgefahren wurden, hat das natürlich auch das R nach oben,
getrieben, weil dort dann teilweise von einer Woche auf die andere doppelt so viele Tests gemacht wurden und wenn man natürlich doppelt so viel Tests macht, selbst wenn die Zahl der Infizierten nicht steigt,
dann äh äh hast du doppelt so viele Fälle. So im Schnitt. Stark vereinfacht. Und dann.
Das RKI jetzt in seinem letzten Bericht vom.
Zwanzigsten zehnten auch 'ne Auswertung vom Probenrückstau und da ist es so, dass.
Als in der zweiunddreißigsten Kalenderwoche die Tests ausgeweitet wurden. Es war sowohl das mit den Reiserückkehrern äh losging.
So ist dann ruckzuck einen Probenrückstau entstanden, also sprich Tests, die nicht am selben Tag bearbeitet werden konnten, sondern erst am nächsten Tag nach Eingang. Frühestens.
Und das bedeutet, ja bei einem aktuellen Probenrückstau von zwanzigtausend Tests äh das ungefähr siebenhundert Infizierte jeden Tag nicht zeitnah benachrichtigt.
Auf der anderen Seite sollten natürlich Leute, die.
Getestet werden auch bis sie das Testresultat kriegen, sich in Quarantäne halten, sodass davon,
eigentlich keine Gefahr ausgehen sollte, aber hm ja. Schön ist das natürlich nicht äh und.
Es entsteht auf jeden Fall eine Gefahr im zweiten Glied, weil
In dem Moment, wenn ich einen positiven Test habe, dann äh benachrichtige ich natürlich alle, mit denen ich in Kontakt war und wenn sozusagen dieser Test ausbleibt, bleibt auch die Benachrichtigung der anderen,
aus und das hatten wir auch vor,
ewigen Sendungen, dass schnell einfach wichtig ist, wenn man Infektionsketten äh unterbrechen will und insofern,
auch wenn wie gesagt die siebenhundert infizierten.
Direktes Problem sind, äh dann es ist trotzdem indirekt ein Problem, wenn man einen Probenrückstau haben.
Und eigentlich sah es so aus,
als wenn der vor zwei, drei Wochen äh langsam äh wieder runtergehen würde, dass das alles abgearbeitet würde. Aber jetzt seit drei Wochen,
baut sich der wieder auf, was vermutlich mit der wieder gestiegenen Zahl der Tests zusammenhängen dürfte.
Obwohl die Testkapazität noch nicht ausgeschöpft wird, also es gibt auch Zahlen zu den Testkapazitäten, die ich jetzt nicht.
Getwittert habe, aber die liegen so ungefähr bei eins Komma sechs Millionen Tests könnten theoretisch,
in der Summe gemacht werden von allen Laboren, aber natürlich,
ist es jetzt nicht so, dass du da ein perfektes Matching hinkriegst, dass alle Labore hundert Prozent fahren, sondern,
einige haben halt, ich weiß nicht, hundertzwanzig Prozent wegen Probenrückstau oder ein Viertel der Labore ist,
über Kapazität während wahrscheinlich die Hälfte oder so oder ein Viertel unter ausgelastet sind, aber so sieht es halt nun mal aus, wenn du hunderte von Laboren hast, das ist nur normal.
Berlin noch. Wie sieht's aus in Berlin? Berlin ist alles Knorke, oder?
Ja, alles, alles ganz toll.
Nee, Berlin äh ja, ich meine generell.
Schon immer der Hotspot. Hier geht's immer ab.
Ja, also vielleicht erstmal bevor wir auf einmal in Berlin führt auch noch den Ländervergleich an, hat jetzt auch insgesamt eine sieben Tage Instit von über hundert, äh das.
Ist schon mal was. Ähm so und an zweiter Stelle dann Saarland und dann kommen so Hessen, Bayern und Sachsen.
Ja die meisten Ostländer oder rein Ostländer halt am.
Tabellenende sich befinden und noch nicht mit Ausnahme von Sachsen noch unter fünfzig liegen.
Ja, bis auf sechs Bundesländer, die jetzt äh alle anderen zehn äh Risikoländer sind.
Und die anderen ja als nächstes wird Niedersachsen dann ähm Risikoland werden.
So wie es aussieht. Ja und jetzt Berlin im besonderen, ja, da haben wir ja schon längst äh alle Stadteignen Rekorde überschritten.
Wobei in Berlin insgesamt är jetzt ein bisschen weniger stark ansteigt.
Als im Bundesvergleich. Also wer Kurve in Berlin ist jetzt nicht ganz so steil äh wie die im Bund, aber auch,
noch verdammt steil,
So und äh auch alles auf Rekordniveau. Außer äh die Zahl der Toten, die.
Auch immer noch eher niedrig lieg.
Also kann man eigentlich nicht viel draus machen. Aus den Zahlen derzeit eigentlich eigentlich alle streben nach oben, die Länder, die unten sind, äh sind zwar unten, aber wollen auch wieder nach oben, also äh,
auch in den Flächenländern verdoppeln sich teilweise die Zahlen und dementsprechend ist da nicht nicht viel.
Ja, also es.
Viel zu holen gerade. Es brennt einfach überall.
Ja, es gibt also jetzt wirklich kein klares Schema, außer dass ja Berlin vorne ist und ähm.
Und viele Ostländer hinten, so kann man's mal vielleicht ausdrücken, aber überall geht's hoch und es gibt in der Risikoliste jetzt auch.
Ja keine grünen Landkreise mehr und erst recht kein super Grün.
Jetzt hat das RKI ja noch äh schöne Grafiken veröffentlicht über die ähm Ausbruchsorte.
Das äh hatten wir auch glaube ich schon mal ansatzweise. Das ist so eine Zusammenfassung.
Die nur einen Ausriss darstellt, ne, die nur ein nur bestimmte Fälle auswertet und da mal schaut, okay, was müssen wir denn darüber, wo hier äh eine Infektion stattgefunden hat? Also Clusterausbrüche, ne.
Ja, also wir hatten sowas, wir hatten diese Tabelle schon mal, die war aber der letzte, die letzte Auswertung war vor zwei Monaten.
Und jetzt gibt's eine mit dem Datenstand vom zwanzigsten zehnten in diesem letzten Bericht ähm und ja da ist es ähm,
nach Infektionsumfeld und Meldewoche. Und.
Leider aber nur Ausbrüche, also die Daten, die einem Ausbruch zugeordnet wurden.
Das ist äh bereits schon mal nur ein Viertel der gemeldeten Daten.
Das heißt, wir gucken hier schon mal von vorne rein nur auf ein Viertel, das heißt drei Viertel,
kann man nicht zuordnen und dann,
sind hier in der Grafik auch noch wiederum ein Drittel aller Ausbrüche äh nochmal rausgenommen, nämlich die mit weniger als fünf Fällen pro Ausb.
So und ja äh das heißt wir gucken hier, ich weiß nicht irgendwo auf fast sechzehn, siebzehn Prozent.
Der Fälle und die sind dann aber relativ hm weit aufgeschlüsselt nach ja.
Gut, dann so Wohnstätten, privater Haushalt, Altenpflegeheim, Flüchtlingsheim, Wohnheim. Das ist alles blau, hat halt also irgendwas mit okay, da wohnen Leute,
dann gibt's so verschiedene Grüntöne für medizinische Behandlungseinrichtung, Krankenhaus und Praxis und Reha-Einrichtung und so weiter,
Ja und da sieht man äh zumindest jetzt mit allen Einschränkungen, dass wir hier nur auf jetzt Cluster ab fünf Leute gucken, sind interessanterweise viele Wohnstätten privater Haushalte,
dabei. So und natürlich Altenpflegeheime, Flüchtlingsheime und Wohnheime, wobei sich privater Haushalt,
nach wie vor der größte Balken in diesem Clusterdingen.
Ist. So, wo man eigentlich jetzt vermuten würde, dass ich im privaten Haushalten eher oder weniger Leute äh an,
stecken oder weniger Leute auf einmal, das heißt
ich würde jetzt erwarten, wenn jetzt auch noch die kleinen Cluster dabei wären und ich verstehe nicht, warum sie die kleinen Cluster jetzt rausgelassen haben. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie.
Die entweder nicht zugeordnet äh haben, aber dass dass die Beschreibung deutet nicht darauf hin.
Vor allem wie viel private Haushalte mit mehr als fünf Personen gibt's denn überhaupt.
Na ja, das wären dann wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Feiern, die dann da stattgefunden haben oder Besucher.
Das zählt dann als privater Haushalt, okay?
Die haben sich dann im privaten Haushalt wahrscheinlich angesteckt bei einer privaten Party, bei Freunden zu Besuch.
Die Feierwütigen.
Feierwütigen.
Das das sind nämlich die Leute, die uns wirklich gefällt. Diese Leute aus privaten Haushalten. Wenn ihr also einen privaten Haushalt wohnt, Shame on you.
Ja
Okay, also es passiert da, wo man zusammenlockt. Alles keine wirklich äh neue Erkenntnis, Altenpflegeheimen, Wohnstätten, äh im Haushalt, wenn viele Leute zusammenkommen, Flüchtlingsheime, gut mach,
nicht so viel aus, aber hat ja auch nur einen gewissen Anteil äh in Deutschland, Wohnheime äh entsprechend. Ich frage mich, ob hier überhaupt irgendwas Nennenswertes rauszulesen ist. Arbeitsplatz. Macht nochmal ein bisschen was aus.
Also am ehesten vielleicht, wenn man sich den zeitlichen Verlauf anguckt, also sagen absolut auf die Gesamtzahl der Infektion ist wahrscheinlich schwierig zu sagen, aber,
man kann zum Beispiel jetzt sagen.
Alten Pflegeheime waren mal vor noch sechs Wochen war da Ruhe im Karton.
Da war also da sehe ich irgendwie.
Kann ich in einem dieser Auswertungen gab es wahrscheinlich deutschlandweit keinen einzigen Ausbruch in dieser,
Woche, was ist das da irgendwo muss das sein? Sechsunddreißig, siebenunddreißig oder so.
Ja war Altenheime spielten keine Rolle. Jetzt aktuell in KW dreiundvierzig haben wir wieder einen richtig fetten Balken bei Alten und Pflegeheimen.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch die achtzig Plus Institanz, die da auch massiv angezogen hat.
Ja und wir haben aber interessanterweise so viele Cluster.
Auch äh oder Cluster infizierte in privaten Haushalten wie nie zuvor.
Das kann man zum Beispiel jetzt auch rausschließen und man kann jetzt auch sagen, dass auch wieder die Infektion am Arbeitsplatz zugenommen haben.
Deutlich da den Tönis, Peak und andere Fleischverarbeitende Betriebe so, wo vierzehn die vierzehn Tage lang.
Diesen Bereich richtig hochgetrieben haben aber danach, na ja, spielte auch immer eine Rolle so.
Aber äh es scheint mir wieder eine größere, eine leicht größere Rolle zu spielen.
Also ich habe auch mit diesen Kategorien so meine Probleme. Also erstmal ich vermisse hier einfach die Kategorie Schule. Hier steht Ausbildungsstätte.
Betreuungseinrichtung.
Schule sehe ich hier irgendwie gar nicht, dann gibt es einen relativ großen grauen Balken, mit der für mich vollständig verwirrenden Bezeichnung weitere.
Heißt das unbekannt oder weitere Kategorien, die man jetzt hier nicht weiter aufschlüsselt wie äh sonstige Parteien.
So ist es.
Ja, aber es ist nicht, dass man einen Großteil auch nicht weiß und der, der hier eigentlich auch drin abgebildet sein müsste.
Nee, der ist äh wie gesagt der.
Einfach nicht mit in den Zahlen.
Ist einfach überhaupt gar nicht mit drin. Äh so, also das sind sozusagen, wie gesagt, drei Viertel sind ja gar nicht mit drin, die gar nicht.
Ja gut, aber es wäre schon mal ganz gut, äh das sozusagen hier auch in der Relation zu haben
weil ich sehe ja hier quasi eine Kurve, die hoch und runter geht und nicht so einen hundert Prozent Teil und eigentlich wäre es sinnvoller, sich das wahrscheinlich mal auf hundert Prozent äh des Betrachtungsbereichs expandiert anzuschauen. Also
das ist wirklich eine eine Auswertung, wo ich sagen muss, die erzählt mir gar nichts,
Klar, Tönnies kann ich jetzt hier irgendwie sehen und irgendwie was mit privatem Haushalt, aber wenn ihr noch nicht mal irgendwie Schule äh als solches abgebildet ist, in irgendeiner Form.
Sie lässt Wünsche offen und es schreibt das RKI auch in dem Bericht, dass das leider nicht so schön ist, wie man das gerne hätte,
vor allen Dingen gibt es auch gar keine es gibt jetzt okay Verkehrsmittel.
Aber sie schreiben auch das Felleben ÖPNV da einfach praktisch nicht drin sind. Ähm,
und das geht also gleich bei Reisebussen und bei äh Flügen aber alles andere so U-Bahnen oder überhaupt Bahn fahren äh ist hier überhaupt nicht mit drin,
das wissen wir gar nicht, was das zum Beispiel beiträgt. Ja äh also es ist ja, es ist äh.
Unbefriedigend.
Ja
Was da ist immerhin bisschen mehr und ach so ja und insgesamt überhaupt hat das RKI jetzt so ein bisschen bei der Datenbereitstellung. Haben sie jetzt mehr Datenquellen auch verlinkt.
Nochmal alles jetzt im Einzelnen äh äh durchgehen,
aber ja da gibt's jetzt ein bisschen mehr. So weil ich ja immer kritisiere. Also sie haben ein bisschen was an der Daten äh Front.
Auch äh getan, äh was so die Verlinkung äh angeht und so, ich muss da nochmal jetzt durchgehen, ob da irgendwas dabei ist, was ich bisher noch nicht kannte.
Okay. Ja, bevor wir ähm,
jetzt vielleicht diskutieren, was uns denn noch so droht. Ähm.
So ein zwei Twitter äh Shreds entdeckt mit einem, ich glaube Mediziner äh von einem Mediziner aus Israel,
der ähm berichtet hat darüber, wie es denn so in den letzten Wochen ähm.
Beziehungsweise letzten Monaten in Israel gelaufen ist. Äh zur Erinnerung, Israel hatte extrem stark ansteigende Infektionszahlen, war auf einmal der totale Ausreißer.
Und ja es äh nahm überhand und dann wurde eben auch ein zweiter Logdown fahr,
Ortnetz und ich will jetzt nicht über diese Definition von Lokdown und so weiter ja wo fängt das an? Wo hört das auf? Dazu komm ich jetzt hier sowieso gleich nochmal, also
Gibt ja immer Leute, die gleich sagen, ja, nee, Lokdown ist ja, wenn alle eingeschlossen werden. Ich denke, das ist jetzt einfach der etablierte Begriff für.
Massivere im Normalfall für das komplette Land geltende Maßnahmen, die mehr oder weniger alle,
treffen und manche natürlich mehr als andere, aber die sozusagen nicht nicht lokal sind, ne.
Und ja äh das ist im Prinzip ein zweiteiliger Analyse. Die erste ist erstmal, was hat überhaupt dazu geführt? Und das äh ist ganz interessant. Äh fängt an und sagt, na ja.
Erster Fehler war wahrscheinlich, dass einfach Schulen mit hohen Infektionszahlen, also wo
Ärger irgendwie um eins herum pendelte, wurden nicht geschlossen, sondern man hat sich dort mit ähm so selektiven Quarantänemaßnahmen beholfen, so Schülerlehrer, die halt in irgendeiner Form betroffen waren. Ja, ihr bleibt jetzt mal zu Hause und so. Man hat einfach nicht konsequent an der Stelle
dicht gemacht, sondern hat die weiter so vor sich hin brüten lassen und äh überhaupt sieht es halt so aus, als ob Schulen ein ganz wichtiger,
Faktor war, ne? Zweiter Fehler, den er ausmacht, ist äh sind, dass die,
allgemein die Maßnahmen sich an der Kapazität des Krankensystems orientiert haben. Dass man immer gesagt hat, na ja, wir haben ja noch Plätze frei.
Passt schon. Äh ist ja nicht so schlimm und wir haben ja in Berlin auch das so als Ampel
dieses ja wieso was wollt ihr denn äh wenn ihr alle wir können euch ja noch Sterbehilfe leisten sozusagen ne und seine These war einfach.
In dem Moment, wo du deine Maßnahmen an dieser Kapazität ausrichtest, dann wirst du sie auch erreichen. Was eine interessante Feststellung ist,
Weitere Feststellungen, ein Ausbruch bei jungen Leuten wird ältere erreichen. Da ist halt einfach irgendwie nichts zu machen. Also man kann das nicht,
trennen und das ist ja auch so Teil der Debatte hier in Deutschland, Christian Drost wird ja auch nicht müde
zu betonen, wie wenig er sowohl von diesem Begriff äh Herdenimonität hält und insbesondere auch nicht von solchen Strategien, wie na ja, betrifft ja im Wesentlichen die Älteren, dann halten wir die halt mal raus,
ja? Schützen die, aber,
den Rest lassen wir mal machen, weil funktioniert nicht. Das sickert einfach durch und das sehen wir ja jetzt in Deutschland auch. Ähm, das hat auch in Israel nicht funktioniert.
Also ja ältere werden halt von jungen betreut und versorgt. Ich mein ja das wird's ja machen.
Man man kann es einfach eine in Illusion, dass man in irgendeiner Form an irgendeiner Altersgrenze so eine Mauer baut und und da hüpft nichts rüber. Das ist das,
funktioniert einfach nicht.
Ja, weitere Feststellungen, ein Ausbruch in einer Stadt wird andere Städte erreichen, also wir haben einfach grundsätzlich zu viel Mobilität so, dafür sind einfach unsere äh Transportwege zu kurz und unsere Möglichkeiten zu vielfältig, äh sei es jetzt, dass die Transportwege als solche greifen oder dass halt einfach Leute in andere Städte äh fahren und
und dort dann eben ihr Unheil ausbreiten. Das ist etwas, was man eben,
auch sehen konnte in Israel und mit anderen Worten eine Maßnahme muss dann letzten Endes auch überall gelten. Ja und dann gibt's noch eine interessante Variante, nämlich ähm,
dass äh in einer Heterogenen Gesellschaft.
Nicht unbedingt alle Maßnahmen überall auf dieselbe Art und Weise greifen und das bezieht sich natürlich jetzt auf die israelische Gesellschaft, die ja im Wesentlichen so drei große Gruppen kennt
Nämlich äh die äh sogenannte normale Bevölkerung, dann äh die arabische Bevölkerung, die nochmal so eine,
besetzte Gebiete et cetera. Ich bin mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht genug ganz so sicher, ob dieser Lokdown in dem Sinne auch die palästinensischen Gebiete mitbetraf. Das da bin ich jetzt nicht äh.
Wird glaube ich nicht, aber es gibt ja auch arabische Bevölkerung in Israel, ja.
Also es ist ja und es ist ja so, dass halt auch viele äh die in den äh ja besetzten Gebie,
Leben äh in Israel arbeiten, die pendeln. Da sind halt viele Pendler. Da wurde zwischenzeitlich auch das Pendeln kurz ausgesetzt, aber äh ja ähm halt schwierig, wenn irgendwie,
deine Leute, die den Müll abholen äh oder so äh nicht zur Arbeit kommen können, schlecht. Ja.
Dritter äh dritte Gruppe,
sind schlicht die orthodoxen. Also diese Hardcore religiösen ähm Juden, die äh natürlich ihr Leben ganz anders gestalten und da hat sich dann eben gezeigt, dass dort die Maßnahmen
so äh nicht so ohne Weiteres gegriffen haben, als als es sich sozusagen,
als allgemein erstmal so ein Veranstaltungstop Stopp etabliert wurde in Israel, haben sich so die Zahlen stabilisiert,
Aber das die Öffnung der Schulen hat dann wieder allem so ein gewisses Feuer gegeben und das lässt sich halt ganz,
an den Zahlen sehen, kaum, dass äh die Orthodoxen und später dann auch die allgemeinen Schulen geöffnet wurden, gegen die Kurve automatisch wieder hoch und das auch relativ schnell und dann halt äh galoppierte das so in den September rein, bis man beschlossen hat
Maßnahmen zu ergreifen und ähm gerade an dieser orthodoxen Bevölkerung könnte man eben auch sehen, wie die sich das eben schnell von den Jungen auf die alten ähm.
Übersetzt hat, dass das da so einfach ein Wochenabstand äh nach oben äh tuckerte
Ja, dann ist natürlich das passiert, was man vermeiden wollte. Man äh ist wiederum an die Grenze der Belastbarkeit bei den Krankenhäusern gekommen und äh ja, hat versucht, damit irgendwie klarzukommen und am neunzehnten oder achtzehnten September zwanzig,
zwanzig wurde dann eben der zweite Lokdown beziehungsweise ausuferndere Maßnahmen.
Beschlossen und zu aller Überraschung war dieser Lokdown schneller,
erfolgreich und von daher viel effektiver als der erste.
Und das, obwohl sowohl die Vorgaben dafür zunächst einmal weniger strikt waren, also nicht ganz so viel Bereiche davon betroffen waren, wie beim ersten Mal und man auch das Gefühl hat, dass ich weniger dran gehalten haben.
Ja, das könnte man hier wahrscheinlich auch erwarten, dass wir eben nicht alles, was jetzt beim ersten Mal betroffen war, wieder in dem selben Maße äh betroffen betroffen werden würde
und ähm das natürlich ist auch einfach Leute geben wird, die sagen, ach scheiß drauf, äh keinen Bock wieder auf den Scheiß vom letzten Mal. Äh mir noch egal,
Trotzdem hat es besser funktioniert.
Ja, also konkret vielleicht noch, was sie gemacht haben, also sie haben sagen,
für drei, drei Wochen beschlossen, drei Wochen Country White Logdown vom achtzehnten September bis zehnten Oktober und das beinhaltete konkret, dass Leute nur in einem,
Radius von fünfhundert Metern von zu Hause sich aufhalten dürfen außer für Arbeit oder ähm.
Essentielle Aktivitäten wie,
äh ja Essen einkaufen, Medizin einkaufen oder Arztbesuche. Dann wurden sämtliche Malls äh Geschäfte, außer jetzt äh essen,
Apotheken, alle Hotels, alle Restaurants, alles Fitnessclubs und Swimmingpools zugemacht
maximal zehn Leute drin, maximal zwanzig Leute draußen, die sich treffen durften, fast alle Schulen wurden geschloßen, außer ein paar Internate und,
Bars und Restaurants dürften nur Delivery machen, nicht mal abholen war erlaub.
Und äh das war auch noch äh.
Sagen während irgendwie Yam im No Reim äh so, das ist ne irgendwie,
sondern spezieller Fire Tag und deswegen gab's dann auch noch spezielle
oder das war auch der Grund, warum sie das zu dem Zeitpunkt gemacht haben, weil sie befürchtet hatten, dass das nochmal richtig einen Schub gibt,
und sagen Outdoor Players, also bieten außerhalb maximal zwanzig Leute
und so innerhalb von Kirchen maximal Gruppen von zehn Leuten, wobei,
sie komplizierte Formeln für wie viele Gruppen jetzt von zehn Leuten in einem Platz sein können und zwar abhängig von der Zahl der Eingänge. So,
Mhm. Ja. Wobei N gleich,
dreimal dreifache Zahl der Eingänge für Eingänge kleiner gleich zwei und in gleich sechs plus zweimal Eingänge minus zwei für je größer zwei.
Eolos Bier-Eingänge. Okay.
Und dann gibt's noch äh außerdem eine Flächenbegrenzung auf Viertel der Fläche in Quadratmetern
So wie viel? Ja. Egal, jedenfalls äh äh ja.
Außerdem eine Synagogen geschlossen. Demonstration nur innerhalb von einem Kilometer Entfernung von zu Hause
und keine ausgehenden Flüge äh auf dem Ben Kurion Flughafen.
Also schon weitreichende Maßnahmen, aber äh muss notimple, es gab halt auch Dinge, die explizit da nicht mit drin waren, zum Beispiel betraf es nicht in dem Maße Arbeitsplätze, die kein, kein, keinen Kundenverkehr haben
Also so Büros, geschlossene Gruppen und so weiter, das war wohl noch möglich, was beim ersten Logdown halt auch anders war, ganz klar
ja, das war jetzt sozusagen die Voraussetzung und natürlich waren die Schulen äh dicht, ne? Und Veranstaltungen und Treffen halt, wie du schon ausgeführt hast, äh, extrem reduziert und.
Was äh warum warum lief es besser, ne?
Ja und die Frage ist vor allem okay, was ist davon übertragbar jetzt auf Deutschland? So, weil die Verhältnisse auch,
der Ausbruch dort ist lang eher offenbar von Schulen ausgegangen und von jüngeren, so was,
Bei uns jetzt nicht so der Fall ist, aber ich denke, dass so die Grundaussagen, dass so einige Grundaussagen, nämlich,
schon hatten. Egal in welcher Altersgruppe es irgendwie anfängt zu brennen. Ähm die anderen Altersgruppen,
kommen mit, das denke ich,
dürfte auch bei uns oder auf auf unsere Gesellschaft übertragbar sein, vielleicht mit einer anderen Geschwindigkeit und so, aber es diffundiert definitiv und ich denke auch, die Sache mit dem Management
nach Belastung des Gesundheitssystems gilt,
auch bei uns einfach aufgrund der zeitlichen Verzögerung und der Geschwindigkeit der Dynamik
die das Ganze hat ist, dass in dem Moment
wo es anfängt irgendwie äh kritisch zu werden. Also sobald du anfängst zu sehen, dass es eng wird im Gesundheitssystem ist es längst zu spät.
Also das ist dann ja, das war's dann.
Um vielleicht nochmal auf diese Analyse äh äh zurückzukommen von diesem ähm Wissenschaftler in Namen sollte ich vielleicht auch nochmal sagen, äh Iran, Segal, der ist beim Weizmann-Institut und äh.
Irgendwie.
Genetischen Ernährung, sonst wie Bereich äh unterwegs. Auf jeden Fall meinte er so, warum es jetzt wirklich besser lief, gibt's keine wirklich.
Genauen Erkenntnisse, also man sieht, es lief besser und man kann jetzt quasi Annahmen machen und eine Annahme, die er gemacht hat, ist halt erstens Schulen, Veranstaltungen, aller Art,
waren geschlossen oder nicht möglich und Masken. Ja, das also einfach das ein Riesenunterschied macht zu der ersten äh zum er.
Ja und aber die Bewegungsfreiheit äh von den Leuten, also keine Reisen, ja? Immerhin fünfhundert Meter.
Das war ja auch beim ersten Mal so. Es geht ja nur die Frage ist, warum war es jetzt effektiver,
obwohl andere Maßnahmen gemacht wurden und ein Unterschied ist, höhere Verbreitung von Masten, die beim ersten Mal, wie wir ja alle wissen, noch nicht so äh mit im Spiel waren und dann eben das,
dass es trotzdem gut funktioniert hat vor allem, also obwohl
weniger Maßnahmen beschlossen wurden, wurden quasi die richtigen Maßnahmen beschlossen. Also es bringt was die Schulen zu schließen, es bringt was Veranstaltungen einzuschränken. Gut aus heutiger Perspektive so ein bisschen so Nobrainer, aber es war ja auch lange unter äh Diskussionen. Auf der anderen Seite eben,
Man kann aber auch Büros weiterlaufen lassen.
So sieht denn eben nicht zu viel Austausch haben. Also es ist alles es hat einfach alles was mit viel Austausch von Leuten zu tun und danach muss man quasi die Maßnahmen machen und die Wirkungen waren auch.
Auf voller Breite, also es ging Infektionen runter, es ging die Fälle runter, es ging äh die äh Einweisung ins Krankenhaus äh runter, die Verläufe waren äh weniger schwer
und dann drei Wochen später sanken eben auch wiederum die Zahl der Todesfälle und äh ja am Ende ähm gilt dann eben,
Maßnahmen fährt man langsam wieder zurück,
Nicht alles, dieses jetzt ist alles supi, sondern man muss halt immer schauen, dass er unter eins gehalten wird. Und ich glaube, das kann man jetzt schon sagen.
So ein bisschen die der Sündenfall in Deutschland, dass wir einfach jetzt zwei fast drei Monate lang.
So diesem R zugeschaut haben und dann so, ja, ist ja so ein bisschen bisschen unter eins, ist ja ein bisschen übereins, tut ja nicht weh.
Bis es einem halt einfach davonläuft und ja und da sind wir jetzt im Prinzip.
Also ich glaube auch, also vielleicht muss man noch sagen zu Israel äh die waren in der Spitze bei äh ja um die siebenhundert hören das ja siebenhundertsiebzehn,
neue Fälle äh pro Million, also ein ähm.
Fälle oder Infektionen? Also.
Neuen ja neue Infektionen, genau, siebenhundertsiebzehn.
Also deutlich höher als wir jetzt sozusagen gerade hier beklagen, aber wie gesagt, es kann halt sehr.
Aber niedriger als Belgien und Tschechien und ja jetzt ähm.
Sind sie wieder runter.
Auf ungefähr das Doppelte von dem, was wir jetzt haben, ja. Das also sind noch nicht noch nicht auf das Level wieder runter, was jetzt gerade bei uns herrscht,
mit ja sechsundachtzig und Israel, naja
Israel ist jetzt bei hundertdreiunddreißig äh so, aber massiv am Fallen halt, so richtig geht so richtig stark runter,
Aber in der in der Tat interessant, dass äh ja dieses Maßnahmenbündel.
Ähm tatsächlich so gut gewirkt hat dort. Ähm,
wird man sehen, äh was bei uns jetzt passiert und wie zielgerichtet die Maßnahmen auf unsere Verhältnisse jetzt sind, weil ich glaube.
Nicht, dass man das sagen jetzt alles eins zu eins übertragen kann. Ähm.
Aber ähm einiges davon sicher.
Ich meine, wir sind uns, glaube ich, doch relativ einig, dass wenn man sich jetzt die aktuelle Entwicklung anschaut.
Relativ unwahrscheinlich zu sein scheint das äh.
Dass wir einem weiteren Lokdown entgehen können. Also irgendeine größere Aktion muss kommen. Das was jetzt bisher getan wurde ist ja im Wesentlichen nur so ein äh Appelliererei.
Was man jetzt ähm aber auch sagen muss, dass es in Deutschland nie so,
radikale Maßnahmen gegeben hat wie in Israel. Selbst beim zweiten.
Shutdown. Jetzt der für Israel weniger scharf war, wäre das trotzdem jetzt für deutsche Verhältnisse äh
Ja, also insbesondere dieses Verbot sich mehr als fünfhundert Meter vom Wohnort zu entfernen
ich meine wir hatten mal fast sowas in der Art, aber es gab da jetzt keine konkreten Meta-Angaben oder so und äh.
Ähm insofern,
Ähm ja, hatten wir nie so nicht so harte Maßnahmen wie Israel.
Ja, ich meine, was so ankündigst und was was die Bevölkerung draus macht, sind, glaube ich, auch nochmal ein paar andere äh Sachen, ne? Also ist immer die Frage, wie gut wird denn sozusagen so eine so eine Maßnahme auch ähm durchgeführt,
angenommen,
Wie ernst wird es genommen, wie genau wird es genommen und inwiefern musst du deine Maßnahmen durch Kontrollen begleiten oder inwiefern musst du sie einfach nur schärfer formulieren, damit sie zumindest halb so gut äh.
Behandelt wird,
her sein, dass die Leute sagen, ab fünfhundert Meter legen mir am Arsch. Ich gehe jetzt hier auch mal einen Kilometer raus und so auf der Entscheidungsetage denkt man sich so, ja.
Kilometer passt auch. Wir haben mal fünfhundert Meter gesagt,
da damit ihr überhaupt zu Hause bleibt sozusagen, ne? Und ähm gut, muss ja nicht nicht unbedingt jetzt so sein wie in Spanien, wo man halt wirklich die Wohnung nicht mehr verlassen durfte, was äh ja auch nun sehr,
Effekt hatte und die Erfahrung von Spanien dann bringen uns glaube ich auch nirgendswo richtig so hin.
Wer in und in Frankreich war's auch ziemlich heftig so äh.
Dementsprechend rechne ich nicht damit, dass wir das jetzt so in Deutschland sehen werden, aber wir werden unter Umständen schon so einen Punkt erreichen, wo es heißt äh Bars, Kneipen,
und vielleicht auch Restaurants dicht nur noch Lieferservice, Bars wieder zu.
Ist nicht schön, ja? Äh aber was soll man sonst machen? Ich meine, man geht halt rum, die Leute sitzen da einfach rum. Vor allem die jungen Leute sitzen da rum. Ich kann sie ja alle verstehen,
Aber es hilft halt leider nichts.
Also ich glaube, man muss sich schon drauf einstellen. Worauf sich äh die Politik offensichtlich auch gerade einstellt, ist, dass die Schulen erstmal wieder geöffnet werden, zumindest gibt's jetzt hier gerade eine Ankündigung in Berlin.
Und da wollte ich jeder mal so ein bisschen drauf äh zu sprechen kommen, dass alle Schulen mit Luftmessgeräten ausgestattet werden sollen. Da ist jetzt in einem Artikel von dreitausendfünfhundert Geräten die Rede. Ich frage mich, ob das wirklich die Zahl der Klassen ist, die wir haben
klingt für mich so ein bisschen wenig, aber vielleicht passt es auch besser als mir das äh das jetzt gerade mir so denke.
Ja, wovon ist die Rede? Ist es von CO zwei Messgeräten die Rede?
Die quasi Anhaltspunkte für ein, wie es so schön heißt, zielführendes Lüftungsmanagement liefern sollen
Also die Ansage mit, mach doch mal die Fenster auf oder äh lüftet mal überhaupt ordentlich durch regelmäßig. Da bin ich mal gespannt, mit was für Grenzwerten die da
ankommen werden. Ich hatte selber schon mal geschaut, ähm, der Markt für CO2 Missgeräte ist ziemlich leergefegt, wie man sich das ganz gut vorstellen kann,
äh habe aber trotzdem zumindest nochmal so ein, so ein, so ein relativ billiges, einfaches Device bekommen, weil ich einfach nur mal so sehen wollte mit was für Zahlen denn eigentlich so in der Wohnung das Ding so daherkommt,
Da werden, ich weiß, was ist denn überhaupt grad die Messeinheit dabei? Es ist äh PPM ähm auf jeden Fall rangiert es immer so zwischen,
Wenn du gut gelüftet hast, so zwischen fünfhundert und wenn's äh wirklich stickig ist zwischen tausendfünfhundert.
Und in dem äh Messbereich äh bewegt sich sozusagen dieses ist okay und ist äh nicht so geil.
In dem Bereich. Jetzt natürlich CO2 nicht das Problem, sondern nur ein Indikator, denn in dem Moment, wo sich das CO2 in so einer Schulklasse oder überhaupt in einem Raum ansammelt, bedeutet das hier, hier wurde viel ausgeatmet.
Viel von dem was ausgeatmet wurde ist halt hier nicht durch Luftaustausch nach außen getragen worden. Und ich meine ich sag hurra ja
Hoffentlich bleiben diese Geräte auch in den verbleiben, diese Geräte auch in den Klassen.
Denn das ist ja nichts, was jetzt nur im äh Zeitalter einer Pandemie ganz hilfreich ist, sondern alle kennen das Problem mit schlecht gelüfteten Klassen und wenn's halt stickig ist und viel CO2 in der Luft ist, na ja, das geht dann halt auch einfach aufs Hirn
So, du wirst halt einfach müde, du wirst unkonzentriert und das ist für keine Klasse gut.
Was zeigt denn das Gerät draußen an? Eigentlich heißt das auch mal.
Ja habe ich noch nicht so konsequent gemacht, muss ich's äh zugeben. Ich hab nur mal richtig lange durchgelüftet und es ging nicht unter fünfhundert und stand relativ nah an der Balkontür.
Okay, wir haben eigentlich also atmosphärisch, eigentlich müsste es jetzt was vierhundert eigentlich äh sein.
Vierhundert ist ja sozusagen das, was gerade allgemein beklagt wird, dass wir da äh jetzt sind, ob sich das so gleichmäßig verteilt, weiß ich nicht. Äh also.
Sollte es also gut auf jeden Fall sind die fünfhundert dann, also ist wahrscheinlich auch Messunggenauigkeit, also ich denke mal, dass das eigentlich, wenn du gut lüftest, müsste es eigentlich an die die eher die vierhundert an
zeigen, aber ich finde das schon mal also das das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass es bis auf tausendfünfhundert hochgeht.
Ja also kann kann funktionieren glaube ich also grundsätzlich jetzt als ich sag mal Lüftungswarengerät,
und insofern.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Indikator. Ich meine mein Teil hat jetzt irgendwie fünfzig Euro gekostet. Das war jetzt äh,
Warte auf mich jetzt nicht so den Eindruck, als ob das jetzt das so totale High-End-Gerät ist, aber es es zeigt halt zumindest was an.
Besser werden natürlich Systeme, die äh auch entsprechende Warnsignale liefern und so, wo man nicht die ganze Zeit draufklotzen muss, aber das hat mir jetzt erstmal gereicht.
Und das ist sozusagen das eine. Dann muss halt gelüftet werden. Ein anderer Ansatz ist natürlich der, na ja,
Wäre ja eigentlich ganz gut, wenn die Luft sich sowieso austauschen würde. Und da haben wir gerade jetzt in Schulen finde ich ein wird da ein interessantes Versäumnis ähm deutlich,
Gut, ich meine schlechte Ausstattung von Schulen ist äh kann man eh permanent beklagen, nur.
Gibt es offensichtlich auch für Neubauten.
Bei Schulen keine Vorschriften darüber, wie das so mit der Lüftung zu funktionieren hat. Also es gibt viele neugebaute Schulen, die genau das gleiche Problem haben, wie die mit Altbauten, dass da einfach kein Lüftungskonzept drin vorgesehen ist.
Ähm das ist mal ganz davon abgesehen, was das jetzt für Auswirkungen äh auf die Pandemie hat und was das für Auswirkungen auch generell auf die Schüler hat,
eben durch die äh schlechte Durchlüftung und das Problem CO zwei. Ähm finde ich das auch allein aus energetischen Gesichtspunkten her schon problematisch, weil wenn man jetzt heute ein Haus neu baut,
ordentliches Verhältnis zwischen,
Dichtheit äh Isolation, ja, Wärme im im Haushalten haben will, einfach um eine ordentliche Energieeffizienz zu haben, nicht so viel Energie zu verbrauchen, nicht vor allem nicht fürs Heizen.
Dann ist einfach der State of the Art heutzutage einfach da mit Wärmepumpen zu arbeiten. Dass du einfach die Wärme im im Haus lässt,
und äh Frischluft permanent zuführst.
Beziehungsweise mit Wärmetauschern kannst du es äh halt auch genau Wärmetauscher in Verbindung, vielleicht mit Wärmepumpen. Da kann man äh auf jeden Fall eine Menge,
rausholen und für warme frische Luft sagen.
Genau, wer mit Wärmetauscher ist auch das, was ich äh sagen wollte. Das äh also quasi,
äh ausgeatmete Luft verbrauchte äh Luft mit hohem CO2-Anteil permanent angesogen wird und nach draußen geführt wird, frische Luft reinkommt, aber die Wärme quasi,
der Abluft vorher entzogen wird. Bärmel bleibt drin, Frischluftzuführ ist permanent, so funktionieren Passivhäuser.
Und jedes moderne Haus sollte im Prinzip so gebaut sein und das ist halt einfach in den Schulen nicht drin. So und,
auch eben bei Neubauten, nicht? Und das ist natürlich ein totales Versäumnis. Jetzt kommen sie halt mit äh Luftmessgeräten
eine andere äh Maßnahme, die ja natürlich jetzt wieder viel zu spät äh kommt, wäre natürlich der Einsatz von sogenannten Luftreinigern. Dass man also ein entsprechendes Gerät dahinstellt.
Würde jetzt, weil baulich kannst du dem Ganzen jetzt nicht mehr beikommen. Kannst ja nicht sagen,
wir bauen jetzt mal alle Schulen um, dass da ein ordentliches Klimaanlagensystem ist, dass es ein Projekt, das dauert zehn, fünfzehn Jahre, äh wenn man mal,
wenn es überhaupt in so einem Zeitraum zu schaffen wäre, wenn man's machen wollte. Luftreinigungsgeräte kann man heute da reinstellen.
Das sind aber sagen wir mal für die benötigten Umwälzungsmengen.
Ja, ist schon recht kostbillige Anschaffung. Also da reden wir schon über so einen niedrigen, vierstelligen Betrag. Also,
die tausend Euro und so weiter, glaube ich kriegt man so Luftreiniger, die die entsprechende Fähigkeit haben, Luftreinigung heißt, die saugen halt permanent Luft an.
Und schieben diese Luf
durch Filter, durch die sogenannten Hipperfilter und wenn man dann so ein äh Hipper-Level dreizehn oder vierzehn hat, dann äh werden eben auch so Partikel im äh Micron Bereich rausgefiltert und das reicht eben auch für Viren,
Sprich Luftreinigungssystem, was halt permanent diese Luft umwälzt bringt jetzt nicht das CO2 raus, aber führt zumindest dazu, dass wir ein rausgefiltert werden.
Aber natürlich kannst du jetzt nicht für Berlin kann jetzt nicht dreitausendfünfhundert hochleistungsreiniger kaufen, weil die gibt's wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr auf dem Markt.
So, ich meine Hepa, sich irgendwie ja als äh Abkürzung für High-Efficiency, Partycule, R oder auf Deutsch auch Schwebstofffilter. Ja.
Ario Rosole. Genau.
Genau. Ja äh ich denke mal alles hilft wahrscheinlich. Ähm,
so
und interessant können wir auch werden, wenn es jetzt implementiert wird, welche Auswirkungen das denn zukünftig, ich weiß nicht, ob Grippewellen hat oder auf Allergien in der Luft oder andere Sachen, wenn wir dann demnächst irgendwie
Ja, gesunde, frische Luft äh in ganz vielen Räumen haben oder ja.
Am Ende steigen sogar die die Leistungen in Mathematik. Und dann Fächer, ne? So.
Nicht wundern, wenn ein Großteil der fehlenden Schulleistung die permanent beklagt wird, einfach was mit dem CO2-Gehalt im Klassenzimmer zu tun hat, ne.
Und mit gleichzeitig abnehmendem Sauerstoffgehalt, das kommt dann auch noch dazu.
Richtig. Genau. Ja ähm übrigens gibt es seit März keine Maseranfälle mehr in Deutschland.
Okay, ja, das wäre vielleicht auch interessant, mal zu gucken äh jetzt äh in dem Surfstud, wie sich denn äh das Monitoring der anderen,
Krankheiten, die da so gemonitort werden, wie die sich denn so parallel entwickelt haben darf. Gibt's auf jeden Fall Daten für und die könnte man sicherlich mal auswerten.
Du meinst ja auch so viel Grippe und was.
Ja, Grippe und alles Mögliche äh.
Stimmt es RKI kümmert sich ja nicht nur um Corona Viren.
Ist jetzt nicht äh ja das K in RKI steht jetzt nicht für Korone. Ähm ja hm.
Damit sind wir eigentlich am Ende, oder?
Ja, nee, eigentlich noch nicht ganz. Die Frage ist äh sozusagen jetzt noch ähm sagen, was was jetzt wahrscheinlich kommt,
so, weil wir hatten ja jetzt schon Szenario Israel so ähm,
und,
Ja, bei uns wird's wahrscheinlich anders äh aussehen und ich hatte noch so eine radikale Idee,
Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt eine Schnapsidee ist, die ist auch noch nicht bis zum Ende durch durchdacht, aber eigentlich,
steckt dahinter so ein bisschen das Grundprinzip, okay, je radikaler du äh,
Ansteckungen verhindern kannst, umso kürzer der Shutdown,
Und eigentlich in der Theorie da Leute maximal für zwei Wochen ansteckend sind,
So sollte es eigentlich möglich sein, wenn du,
jetzt in zwei Wochen sämtliche Ansteckungen unterbindest oder sag mal neunundneunzig Komma neun neun Prozent, dann hast du eigentlich nach zwei Wochen, hast du Ruhe.
Theoretisch könntest du sogar in zwei Wochen das Virus ausrotten auf diese Weise, wenn das perfekt gelingen würde, ja?
Genau. Deswegen,
wäre meine Idee äh okay, warum nicht mal und das hat ich weiß nicht, vielleicht also China, selbst China hat das glaube ich nicht so oder vielleicht sollen wir mal gucken, aber,
die Idee wäre halt ähm ja zwei Wochen oder drei Wochen oder vielleicht eine Woche, je nachdem eine,
wirklich totale Ausgangssperre, also so äh weit ist irgend nur möglich ist äh so und zwar,
praktisch niemand verlässt seine Wohnung für zwei Wochen oder sein Arbeitsplatz, je nachdem was irgendwie wichtiger ist.
Ja ähm gut ja ich sehe schon diverse Probleme, aber,
ja grundsätzlich macht alles zu, sogar Supermärkte und der ÖPNV fährt nicht mehr. Tankstellen werden dicht gemacht mit ein paar Ausnahmen, also offen bleiben Krankenhäuser, Arztpraxen, Polizei,
Feuerwehr, aber die Leute bleiben vor Ort,
Also er kann sich dann entscheiden, entweder du bleibst zu Hause oder du bleibst auf Arbeit zwei Wochen. Aber hin und her ist.
Total geil.
So. Ähm ja und gut dann muss halt sicherstellen, dass irgendwie Kraftwerke weiterlaufen, Gas und Wasserversorgung und Fernheizung und Tiere müssen betreut werden,
Wahrscheinlich kommt dann noch, wenn man da länger drüber nachdenkt, kommen da noch so ein paar kritische Sachen dazu, aber,
ja äh das Ganze mit Vorbereitung so, dass alle rechtzeitig halt auch für zwei Wochen, also es einplanen können und entsprechend Vorräte,
einlagern, dass man halt dann vorzieht auch Transporte und so, weil so generell irgendwie mit LKWs und Zeugs durch die Gegend karren und so. Äh ne,
ja alle Grenzen dicht,
Hm und eigentlich null Verkehr zwischen äh mach's halt auch noch Straßensperren zusätzlich, ja? Mit Kontrollen, dass auch wirklich nur wer,
irgendwie Papier hat, auch fahren darf so. Also.
Pavel, die totale Merkel-Diktatur.
Aber dann, also ganz ehrlich.
Ja. Gut, mir persönlich jetzt meine Meinung. Ich hätte lieber so sagen, zwei Wochen oder meinetwegen auch drei Wochen,
zu Hause bleiben und dann ja wer erstmal wenn man bis auf Weiteres,
Ja, wer erstmal Ruhe, also wahrscheinlich könnte man mit mit so einem Shutto hält man die Zahlen in zwei, drei Wochen auf einen Zehntel oder hundertstel reduziert von dem, was da jetzt läuft,
bin ich von überzeugt, aber ja,
wer weiß, vielleicht irgendjemand probiert's vielleicht nochmal, Deutschland wahrscheinlich eher nicht. So und gutes andere Problem ist natürlich eigentlich müssten es,
in Europa alle machen. Bringt halt nichts, wenn nur Deutschland das macht. Ähm,
Ja und dann gehen die Grenzen wieder auf und dann kommt's halt wieder wie im Sommer alles rein. Also gut. Äh,
Nein, ich hab's jetzt auch nicht durchgerechnet. Es ist natürlich dann auch super teuer,
äh so was. Also es ist alleine eine Woche sind halt wahrscheinlich so drei bis fünf Prozent vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt würden dann flöten,
gehen äh so pro Woche. Ja, also.
Also vielleicht ist es auch noch eine Schnapsidee, aber wer weiß, vielleicht äh ähm ja, vielleicht auch doch nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall ich jetzt vor zwei Stunden getwittert oder so und ich war jetzt nicht der einzige der lieber zwei Wochen lang zu Hause bleiben würde äh wenn das.
Ja. Also ich meine da fallen mir locker viele Fälle ein von Leuten, die wirklich überhaupt gar keinen Bock haben ähm.
Zu Hause zu bleiben. Ich meine, hasse so Probleme wie äh Leute, die Betreuung brauchen ähm
ne. Äh dann äh natürlich das große Problem häuslicher Gewalt, was äh dadurch natürlich auch nochmal so eine andere Spitze bekommt. Also es bräuchte zumindest einen gewissen Vorlauf,
ob wir den jetzt überhaupt noch haben.
Definitiv Planung und Vorlauf, also du kannst es nicht irgendwie von einem Tag auf den anderen machen, sondern du musst sowas eigentlich über Wochen vorbereiten. Und auch Lösungen finden für äh Halt,
individuelle Probleme und so und äh ja aber das wäre halt,
mal eine Variante, ich weiß nicht, ob die irgendwie überhaupt diskutiert worden ist. Äh ich glaube, China war ziemlich nah dran an.
Ja, in Wuhan haben die auf jeden Fall da äh ordentlich äh ordentlich zugeschlagen, was solche Einschränkungen betrifft. Und das ich hatte ja, ich habe er hatte ja auch über den äh den Lokdown hier auch,
gesprochen vor einiger Zeit,
Der Katharine Thai und ähm die hat da sehr viel Einblick hat in äh in China und meinte na ja, es wäre halt für die Leute aber auch wirklich hochgradig traumatisch gewesen.
Also es gibt da auf jeden Fall eine Grenze, ne. Äh.
Mhm. Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, wenn du dir die China-Kurve anguckst im Vergleich mit allen anderen.
Ja seit seit der ersten Welle, nein, eigentlich durchgängig. Genau, in der ersten Welle, so im Februar,
China irgendwo mal bei einer Institanz von drei. Ja? Vergleich.
Auf ganz China bezogen. Gut Wuhan war sicherlich höher so, aber seitdem äh sind die irgendwo.
Null Komma null null. Wie man auf null Komma null fünf null Komma null eins und China ist auch das einzige Land, wo die Wirtschaft wieder wächst.
Ja, muss man auch dazu sagen. Also China wird eine der wenigen Länder, es absehbar in zwanzig zwanzig äh positive Wachstumszahlen,
verkünden könnten, ja. Das ist die andere Seite der Medaille,
es ist nicht so, dass man sagen kann, okay, das war jetzt war jetzt nur die privaten Leute, sondern es wurden halt auch alle Firmen einfach zugemacht.
Ne? Also war nicht wurde auch keine Rücksicht auf die Wirtschaft genommen. So und es ist natürlich dann jetzt die Frage,
Ähm was was will man, ja? Am Ende, ich meine äh ja, äh ist China jetzt durch.
Diese verdammte Geschichte äh sagen, geht China wahrscheinlich weltweit als äh Gewinner äh aus dieser ganzen Krise hervor.
Einfach durch ein konsequentes Pandemie-Management.
Und das ist natürlich ich sag mal auch nicht gut für die Systemfrage.
Nee, kann man nicht sagen.
Es ist nicht gut.
Ja, genau, wie sieht's denn aus in der freien Welt, ne? Also nicht so geil, ja. Das stimmt.
Es ist leider ja nicht so schön und vor allen Dingen, ja, ich meine, wir haben jetzt,
Oktober, ja? Es ist jetzt noch nicht so super kalt, also äh November und der Dezember und der Januar und der Februar und der März liegen noch vor uns mindestens und der April,
Ähm so ich mein die sollen das, wie sollen das gehen.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also das mit der Systemfrage ist wirklich äh gut. Ich habe mir jetzt gerade nochmal bei Auerworld in Detail einfach mal so die ganzen Kontinente zusammengeklickt, einfach nur mal so Azure World, North Americas, House America
ja, also am schlechtesten steht gerade die EU da
Gefolgt von Europa als Ganzes, gefolgt von United States so
Nord- und Südamerika insgesamt äh gleich auf, schlecht so, äh dann äh immer noch doppelt so schlecht wie die Welt im Durchschnitt. Asien ist im Schnitt irgendwo so bei,
fünfundzwanzig Cases äh pro Million und die Chinakurve,
platt gedrückt unten an dem Balken, so dass man überhaupt nicht mehr sieht, da ist sie, da gab's dann im März so einen ganz kurzen Hubbel. So und dann seitdem ist es einfach platt. Okay, die hatten auch nochmal so einen Zwischenausbruch im August, aber das ist halt einfach nichts
im Vergleich zu dem, was wir erleben. Nichts, das ist ein Hauch davon.
Ja und deswegen, wie gesagt, die äh chinesische Wirtschaft läuft soweit, hm sie halt nicht von Exporten jetzt begrenzt äh betroffen ist, läuft wieder auf Hochtouren und ja,
muss man sagen das ist nicht gut, das Bild des die freie Welt gerade.
Der bei unserer Freiheit muss doch erhalten bleiben. Funktioniert bloß grad nicht so richtig gut.
Nicht wirklich.
Gut, ich will äh zum Ende dann doch nochmal mit was äh amüsanten kommen.
Zumindest was was sagt man so schön, aber Samsting Uplifting.
Weiß nicht, ob du das äh gesehen hast die Lösung ähm der äh wie heißt die noch gleich? Äh der Bergbrauerei bei Ulm.
Mhm. Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ähm also alle Restaurants haben ja dieses Problem mit, man muss ja seine Adresse hinschreiben. Ne? Und äh,
Hatten wir ja nun auch schon öfter ist jetzt nicht so beliebt,
Warum sollte man das tun? Was hat man davon? So, im schlimmsten Fall wird man auch noch irgendwie vom Gesundheitsamt äh angerufen und in Quarantäne geschickt. Also viele machen's gar nicht oder wenn sie's machen, geben sie vielleicht auch nicht die vollständige Information an.
Die Bergbrauerei,
also da so eine so eine offene Wirtschaft betreibt. Hm man muss natürlich das auch erfassen und gibt aber diese Karten in Form von Postkarten raus.
Wo du dann sozusagen deine Adresse drauf schreibst und damit automatisch auch eine Postkarte ähm adressierst, an dich selbst,
und das Versprechen der Brauerei ist, dass wenn du äh die richtig adressiert hast,
Und die Frist dann für die Aufbewahrung abgelaufen ist nach vierzehn Tagen, dann wird die halt dadurch vernichtet, indem sie halt einfach in einen Briefkasten gesteckt wird,
und zu dir geschickt wird,
übernehmen also auch noch das Porto, was weiß ich, worauf die sich da geeinigt haben, aber es sieht so aus, als ob sie die vollen sechzig Cent abdrücken dafür. Und dann erreicht dich das und wenn da halt äh der Stempel äh drauf ist von dieser Bergbrauerei,
dann ist das halt auch gleich noch ein Gutschein für ein Freibier beim nächsten Besuch.
Eine super geile Idee, um da den hochzuhalten, um wirklich die richtigen Daten anzugeben. Und auch noch gleich ein Entsorgungskonzept für äh diesen Datenkram.
Voll gut, oder?
Ja? Klingt, klingt in der Tat, klingt gut.
Weiß nicht, ob sich das für die wirklich rechnet.
So, weil sie ja dann doch relativ viele Freibiergutscheine äh rausgeben und nochmal sechzig Cent und Aufwand äh da rein. Äh K
müssen, aber ich meine, wir wissen auch alle, wenn man jetzt mal so die Marge auf so einem Bier und bei einem Bier bleibt's ja dann nicht und so weiter, also das wird sich dann wahrscheinlich schon auch irgendwie rechnen.
Grandios.
Nee, finde ich eine super Idee. Wobei natürlich jetzt äh also sagen.
Paranoida äh äh würde ich dann sagen, na ja, dann müsste vielleicht,
noch auch ein spezieller Code drauf oder vielleicht auch eine Gesetzgebung, dass wenn die Post dann mit ihren Sortiermaschinen diese Postkarten scannt und sortiert, damit äh dass die,
dann sagen auch gelöscht werden die Daten und nicht,
gespeichert. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das äh überhaupt mit den Daten aussieht, wie die aufbewahrt, wie lange die aufbewahrt werden äh so, aber ich weiß, dass die Daten halt aufbewahrt werden.
Gut, ich meine, das ist natürlich eine generelle Frage der des Datenschutzes bei der Post, das ist ja jetzt erstmal anrelated und äh betrifft jetzt, glaube ich, die Brauerei nicht. Ich fand das einfach einen klugen Move und äh so muss man kreativ damit umgehen.
Ansonsten die ja die Idee ist wirklich ziemlich genial, das stimmt. Grundsätzlich, wenn nicht, wie gesagt, da jetzt wieder.
Irgendwas dagegen spricht.
Wäre äh genau, wenn der nicht die Post mit ihren elektronischen äh ähm Sortiermaschinen und Scannern äh wäre.
Freibier für Daten.
Ansonsten gut vielleicht um auch nochmal nicht ganz so negativ jetzt das äh.
Ausschauen zu lassen. Also wir werden's auf jeden Fall überleben, die meisten von uns.
Das klacke jetzt mal.
Äh kann man.
Positiv.
Schon mal sagen, also es wird auch und es wird auch ein Leben nach Corona geben, was äh äh ja äh doch sehr große Ähnlichkeit mit dem Lieben vor Corona äh haben äh wird, aber,
das kann halt noch ein Jahr oder zwei dauern.
Das war ja auch die Einschätzung von von Lars, von Lars Fischer, mit dem ich hier vorletzte Sendung äh gesprochen habe über die Situation meinen Impfstoffen. Ich weiß, was zu diesem Zeitpunkt das noch nicht äh nachhören äh können. Er meinte er im Kern auch. Na ja
Bin jetzt irgendwie mit den Impfstoffen das irgendwie alles äh schiefgeht, weil so wie sich die Infektionszahlen jetzt äh entwickeln, ist das Ding dann wahrscheinlich zwanzig zweiundzwanzig sowieso durch, auf die eine Art oder andere
die ein oder andere Art. Ähm ja, dann halt natürlich mit mehr Todes äh Fällen und entsprechenden Nachwirkungen, aber irgendwann,
Irgendwann ist dann eben auch eine eine so große Verbreitung erzielt, dass es sich halt einfach nur, dann wird's wirklich sozusagen die nächste Grippe. Und ähm.
Wird's auch irgendwann wieder in einen Normalmodus übergeben. Aber noch haben wir die Möglichkeit, das Ganze äh mehr in unserem in unserem Willen zu steuern.
Ja, ja. Also manchmal hilft es auch, sich den Worst Case vor Augen zu führen und.
Der Worst Case jetzt aus Epidemiologischer Sicht ist, dass in Deutschland einige hunderttausend Menschen sterben, so.
Und äh die meisten äh davon äh tatsächlich,
in den höheren Altersgruppen und ich habe das mal auch so in auf Berlin jetzt für die Jüngeren, für die zwanzig bis Dreißigjährigen, äh würde man wahrscheinlich ungefähr,
Tote in dieser Altersgruppe ungefähr kommen. Also ist nicht so, dass jetzt die jungen Leute nicht betroffen wären.
Aber ja, also das wäre jetzt sozusagen der Worst Case, den wir natürlich alle nicht wollen, weil äh.
Die Begleitumstände mit meinen italienischen Verhältnisse und so.
Das möchten wir glaube ich alle nicht plus das das natürlich dann auch wenn wir halt.
Richtig dadurch äh laufen, dann kann das natürlich äh auch noch äh,
Langzeitfolgen, also gesellschaftliche Langzeit äh äh Folgen haben, die dann nicht so schnell weggehen, deswegen denke ich äh gibt es viele gute Gründe, diesen Worst Case äh auf jeden Fall zu vermeiden,
aber im Verhältnis zu.
Mal anderen Katastrophen in die in den letzten hundert Jahren stattgefunden haben, würden wir es überstehen.
Gut. Damit sollten jetzt alle ausreichend gute Laune haben,
Wir gucken mal ähm ob's nächste Woche zum Corona Vicky äh kommen wird jetzt, wo ich äh mehr und mehr Terminabsagen reinkriege, habe ich unter Umständen mehr Zeit als ursprünglich gedacht.
Und äh ja.
Ja im Moment wird's eher andersrum bisschen langweilig so, weil seit zwei Wochen ja eigentlich nur noch ständig dieselben steigenden Zahlen zu verkünden. Wir haben zumindest was Deutschland angeht, aber.
Ja
Also liebe Leute, benehmt euch ordentlich, damit Pavel ähm und wir alle wieder mal interessantere verläuft. Verläufe sehen kann. Gut, dann sagen wir tschüss, Pavel.
Und ansonsten ja bleibt alle trotzdem gesund, passt auf euch auf.
Pass auf alle anderen auf.
Und passt's auf alle anderen auf.
Immer schön die Maske über die Nase ziehen. Mhm.
Mhm. Und Abstand halten.
Mhm. Und all das. Und äh gesund im Kopf bleiben vor allem. Lasst euch nicht runterkriegen. Ich sage tschüs.
Tschüs.